the film hoda it's the story of a
teenage girl who has this deaf family
there's a scene in the film this school
concert and we get to ruby's performance
and right when you're ready to hear her
we go to complete silence and shift povs
to this family they are starting to look
around to get perspective on you know is
she good are people enjoying it
they go home they're about to go into
the house and frank wants a moment alone
out on the truck ruby sees that moment
and then frank asks her that song you
sang tonight what was it about
the lyrics of that song are really
really resonant in that moment he says
can you sing it for me
[Music]
and it was plain to see
you
were my destiny
[Music]
i was grateful that most of the singing
like all of the singing was live on set
because in one of the takes he was like
more louder and i didn't know he was
going to do that and so then i had to
sing louder and so much of it just came
alive on set when we were together
i said troy you get amelia to sing loud
enough so that you can feel something
and amelia you get him to feel something
i will go
where you lead always
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was so emotional what happened it's
not that he magically got to have music
it's that he had a very intimate
connected experience with his daughter
of understanding something that she
loves and he gave her that
moment she busted into tears and
everyone else that busted into tears it
was a great scene to do because so much
changed on the day and it was kind of we
were living
[Music]
you